thank you the might the career that I've
led that led up to the system we did for
the America's Cup was a bit complicated
and both I've really had two careers in
parallel one is a professional navigator
and sailing and the other much more
conventionally in technology but to
really understand the background of the
America's Cup I really need to give you
the background of both and to my
astonishment on both of those careers
actually contributed to one another to a
degree that I never could have imagined
and actually led to the America's Cup so
originally I graduated from Yale in 78
in engineering and then came out and got
a job at essar I international I worked
in the remote measurements lab on sort
of conventional defense electronic
systems over-the-horizon radar precise
radio positioning system underwater
optics things of that nature and I
participated in the honors co-op program
at Stanford and so it was a terrific
experience getting my masters here at
Stanford during the time I was at sr i--
i left sr i-- in 1983 with three others
and eventually six others from sr i--
and we founded attack which was the
first of the vehicle navigation systems
there was a couple of interesting
aspects of attack which is an actually
ll corn here and it was quite a bit
about it but attack predated GPS so we
couldn't figure out where we were by
using GPS we had to figure out where we
were by using Matt matching so we had a
compass and wheel sensors we measured
the path the vehicle traveled in and
then we eliminated the accumulation of
uncertainty and error in the position by
cross correlation between the path the
vehicle is taken and the available roads
in the map database taking advantage of
course that of the fact that drivers
tend to use roads and we know where the
roads were the but we were kind of ahead
of our time and so we had to solve a lot
of problems that people didn't have to
solve later we had to not only solve the
map matching
navigation problem we had to figure out
a topological structure to store the map
efficiently we had to do our own you
know compass sensor fluxgate compass
sensor we had to do our own storage
device you can see the storage device
was based on a Phillips cassette like
form factor but made of lexan for the
heat and without the capstan so we could
move the tape very quickly we had to do
our own operating system for that memory
was expensive so we had to do our own
display we couldn't use a bitmap display
so we used a vector display where we
drew the vectors directly on the screen
so it was a major undertaking but we did
get a vehicle navigation system the
first one introduced it in 85 we
licensed all the major automakers etek
was a success from the standpoint of the
initial investors not a huge you know
retire on it success but sort of a okay
success we sold it to news corporation
in 1989 News Corporation then resold it
during their debt crisis to Sony it then
changed its name and ultimately was sold
the tomtom for six billion none of us
participated in that yeah unfortunately
we didn't participate in any of that
where would be once connected let's
write the rich I we did a rage era that
was a flexible disk variable capacitance
ray gyro that was used up until quite
recently in a sailboat navigation
systems meanwhile I was pursuing another
kind of part-time career on the side
which is navigating professionally for
major offshore racing events and this is
something I did I've done since college
and the funny thing was is this really
tied into my other stuff meeting Nolan
Bushnell I was asked to navigate his
boat to an attempt to win the transpac
which we did in 1983 and Nolan was the
guy as many of you know who was one of
the co-founders of Atari and developed
with ll corn here the first video game
pong and nolan i got to know Nolan
navigating his boat and was able to
convince Nolan to give me the seed
financing to start attack Roy Disney and
navigated his pocket he invested both in
attack and was a significant investor in
the seed money for sport vision many
years later Larry Ellison I navigated on
sayonara Larry of course was the guy
that funded the system that we're going
to talk about a little later which is
the augmented reality for the America's
Cup Steve Fossett was an investor in
both of the company's navigated for
Steve on a number of his boats the
biggest of which was PlayStation and
then of course Richard Branson on virgin
later during the period from 2004 to
just before the beginning of the
America's Cup in 2010 I actually sailed
full-time and I navigated in the Volvo
round-the-world race which is the
pinnacle event for a navigator and we
won that in 2006 and then I navigated to
set the non-stop record around the world
in 2010 and it was actually during this
event I was still in the Southern Ocean
or the South Atlantic on the way to the
finish when Larry Ellison was
interviewed he'd just won the America's
Cup and people asked Larry so you say
you're going to do great TV what are you
going to do and Larry said to my
astonishment that he was going to look
up an old sailing colleague you know
Stan honey and we were going to put
graphics on the water because amazingly
back in 95 when I was navigating for
Larry we'd had that conversation that I
was then developing working on the
hockey puck in the first down line and I
mentioned to Larry that the sports that
benefit from augmented reality meaning
the insertion of graphics into the field
that play live are those sports where
there's important things that happen in
the sport that are hard to see and
there's no sport that has more of that
than sailing and so to my amazement
Larry remembered that yes get a quick
shot away the gis question the male's
question so your life
does she comment you do not ask for
directions like the rest of the guys it
was absolutely astonishing but all of us
who were in the founding group of v-tach
none of us could find our way out of a
paper bag and we all thought that this
was just you know an enormously
important product and I can navigate
just fine offshore you know with tools
and charts and all that but none of us
do very well that's very different
approach the other interesting thing and
this was you know the attack patents
ended up being enormously important and
valuable one whole category of the
patents was in map matching which even
though we have GPS today Matt matching
Pat Mac matching is still used because
GPS looks sloppy on a display so people
are still using the original map
matching algorithms to keep the boat on
to keep the car on the roads the the
other interesting thing that we
discovered and today it seems
preposterous to imagine but it wasn't
clear to us at all what to do with the
map and it wasn't until we done a bunch
of experiments that we realize that the
clues to your surrounding are so strong
that the map needs to rotate and the car
needs to be fixed in the center heading
up and the map needs to scroll past the
road as it moves because even though
those of us that are used to navigating
think in a north up world in a car the
visual clues are so strong that if you
have a north up map you see people kind
of rotating their head when they're
going south and so that was something
that also turned out to be an enormously
valuable set of patents for the rotating
map and the heading and that turned out
to be the source of the name for the
company because the Polynesian term for
a canoe centered world way of thinking
about the world is attack yes
they do in spite of the fact that you
know they're standing upside down but
their charts other than the joke charts
are still North up so the so we sold he
tacked a news corp which at that point
was the 10 billion dollar media company
that was owned and run and still is by
rupert murdoch and then I continued to
run e tack for a few years News Corp got
into a bit of a debt crisis I was asked
to settle attack which I did to Sony but
I was asked to stay on at News Corp
because News Corp was then facing a lot
of technical issues and Rupert asked me
to be the senior VP of Technology for
all of news corporation that started in
about 90 for the I discovered to my
astonishment that it was a staff job and
I hadn't really known what that meant
and what I discovered that it met at
least in a big media company is it meant
spending all your time flying around and
going to meetings but not actually doing
anything that felt like it was very
constructive so I was very unhappy there
but I decided to get happy by doing
stuff one of the guys that I got to know
was David Hill who was then starting Fox
Sports I'm David asked me to meet with
him every couple weeks and brief him on
technologies that could impact the
broadcast of sports one of those lunches
where I was briefing him i briefed him
on the fact that it was just then
becoming possible in 1994 to have the
computer power with you know SGI
computers to do a live graphic insertion
in live video of something that was
correctly positioned relative to the
real world in the example I gave was you
could put in a fake billboard David
responded with something I was to hear
many many times through the years which
is that was the stupidest thing you'd
ever heard but if you could do that
could you do something useful like could
you do something that would actually
help the sport so David asked if we
could track and highlight the hockey
puck I told them that yeah we tracked
much tougher things at essar I but that
he couldn't afford it
he explained to me that I may not
understand the economics of sports
broadcast and asked me to figure out
what it would cost so I spent a couple
of weeks thinking of a few different
ways to do it and checking him out and
so that I wrote David Hill an email I'm
telling him that it would cost two
million dollars and it would take two
years to build such a system but that we
could do it I got a phone call from
Rupert Murdoch not ten minutes later
saying you can track and highlight a
hockey puck in two years for two million
bucks and I said yeah and he said do it
so that was the beginning of the Fox
Trax puck we did it it was 2.2 million
so it was a very slight overrun but we
we scored that as a victory and we did
it in two years and it was introduced at
the all-star game in 96 it's an active
puck it well I'll show you how that
works and it was very unpopular with the
diehard fans they hated it because part
of the macho of hockey is you don't need
to see the puck and of course in
standard def TV you couldn't see the POC
infection you can just barely see a
shadow of it there but nevertheless the
non fans liked it and it resulted in the
highest NHL ratings that NHL had ever
had but the diehard fans hated it but
continued to watch that's what it means
to be a die-hard fan the way it worked
was we had all the broadcast cameras
around the rink were instrumented so
they had pan tilt sensors relative to
the tripod they had zoom focus sensors
and we had we surveyed where they were
so we knew for every field the video
from every camera where the real world
appeared in each field of video we knew
the point of view in the field of view
of each of the cameras and then we knew
where the puck was because the puck had
we cheated we put in infrared emitters
in the puck the puck emitted quite
bright 100 micro second pulses of
infrared 30 times a second we had
sensors around the arena that had cavity
interference filters so they were just
sensitive to the exact wavelength of
that infrared
and the shutters were just open during
that hundred microseconds so we had
enormous signal the clutter in the
system and so we were able to track the
puck when the puck was you know in a
pile of people or when it was in the
officials pocket and the reason we
needed to use in active system is that
you know a black puck that's three
inches across there's a lot of black
things with sort of 3-inch dimensions in
a hockey arena you know the sticks
ankles elbows and so in the time when
you're most interested in where the puck
is is not only when it's moving quickly
but when its people are fighting over it
and the puck you know may score it out
to the side and nobody notices and so we
had to cheat and build the system that
had you know enormous signal declutter
to make it work in that environment so
there you can see the inside of the puck
that's got a battery in that gold
cylinder there's an accelerometer that
knows to turn it off and on that's right
there you have the infrared emitters in
the the timing circuitry and so forth
and then we would synchronize to the
park externally with sync sensors the
once we did the puck we kind of knew we
were onto something that there were a
number of sports where there was
something important that was hard to see
and the next obvious example was
football the interesting thing that
happened though was that News Corp I
caught news corp at a bad time and I
wanted to keep the group together
because I dragged a bunch of guys from
sr I and then from e tack and we all
enjoyed doing this stuff and I'll
enjoyed working together but I caught
News Corp during their debt crisis and
they didn't want to you know pay to do
the yellow line but we invented it while
we were still at News Corp so that
actually David Hill as name is on the
patent so what I did is I negotiated a
deal with Rupert Murdoch and I spun a
new company out of news corp it was a
great deal what I did was I got all of
the patents all of the technology all of
the equipment the production truck our
offices the all the furniture everything
in exchange for Rupert keeping ten
percent of the new company and then to
come up with the operating capital we
needed I went
to Roy Disney whose boat I was
navigating at the time that's showing
how these things do tend to weave in and
out and then we also raised some of the
money from Fred Wilpon the guy that
owned the Mets at that time I guess
still does so we introduced the first
down line in 1998 and unlike the puck it
was hugely successful from the very
beginning and the first down line very
quickly rolled out through all of
American broadcast of football both NFL
and NCAA the it was a little tougher
though the cameras were instrumented in
the same way the cameras are mounted on
tripods and we measured the pan tilt
zoom focus of each of the cameras we had
to measure the crown of the field
because football fields with one
exception they're all have crown either
curvature or v-shaped so that they drain
water and then we needed to measure the
distortion of the lens very accurately
because the yard lines have curvature
due to the distortion of the lens and we
needed the fake yard line to curve
exactly the same way in lie you know
alongside the real yard lines so to keep
the illusion the other thing that was
different and harder was that in the
puck we just keyed the trail of the puck
on top of everything whereas in the
first down line to create the illusion
that it was on the ground we had to draw
around the athletes and we did that by
color so what we would do at first is we
would take a group of pixels and we
would look at the color and if that was
in an inclusion color space that was
relative to the mud or the grass then we
turn it yellow and in some cases we
would have an exclusion color space like
the green the particular green and the
packers jerseys and not drawn that and
that actually was the thing we were most
worried about and it was one of those
rare things and all of our careers where
it worked much better than we thought in
fact we didn't think it was going to
work very well and it continues to work
you know far better than intuitively
makes sense
in 2000 we introduced the k-zone we
track the baseball from about a metre
after the pitcher to just before the
strike zone much easier to track than a
hockey puck because the background is
constant we look at it from high first
and high home you're looking down
against the grass which is stationary so
just conventional motion detection
algorithms like sequential frame
differencing the ball stands out
perfectly so you can triangulate figure
out where the ball is measure its
trajectory I think it's like ten
something I mean we use a fairly high in
a field rape camera but we have plenty
of measurements so that we know just
where the ball is and in fact when we
initially introduced the system the
principal objective was just where the
ball crosses were mrs. the strike zone
but then later people became very
interested in all kinds of other things
about the trajectory of the ball and in
fact it was actually an interesting
system the when we introduced it the
officials in baseball were just
violently against it and within about
two weeks the officials in baseball were
our biggest advocates because what we
showed was that the officials do a much
better job than anybody had imagined and
a lot of the outfield cameras really
hard on center line and so as soon as
that system was put in place the
officials realized that it was actually
supporting them and so then there was a
lot of pressure to equip all ballparks
and now the officials get that data even
for games where the system isn't used
the officials use that data to measure
their own performance and to see who
needs training and all of that but the
overall conclusion was the officials did
far better than anybody had known ously
they're all framelock so that's the
picture is time register for all to me
people yes in fact all of this
inserting graphics into live video time
is absolutely critical that you need to
have you know where everything is
relative to the field time of every
camera and of course in this case you
know the same thing is true of the puck
and if you have just slight delays when
a cameramen jerks his pan or is tilt or
focus you'll see a delay and the overlay
relative to the real world and that and
when you make a mistake in an augmented
reality system like this and we do a
different kind of augmented reality than
the kind that you do in a cell phone or
something whereas we're actually trying
to fool people and we get to cheat we
get to delay the real video so we get
the time to do stuff in advance and in
the case of the original hockey system
we would delay the real video by two
full seconds now we're down to less than
half a second but nevertheless we got to
delay the video you get the graphic
calculated that you're going to overlay
on top of each field the video in
advance because you can't stop real time
and then the timing has to be perfect
and one of the last things we do before
a broadcast just to double check is we
do pan tests and zoom tests on the
cameras we reach cameramen we'll put a
graphic up in the real world then the
cameraman will jerk the camera back and
forth and we'll make sure that that test
symbol stays fixed on the ground and
that's just a way of checking the timing
through the entire production truck
because the production trucks are
complicated the last minute they can
change the way they routed the system
and put in another graphic processor and
you know add another slight delay or
take it out a we use GPS yeah in almost
all systems we use GPS time and TV for
the most part they care about relative
time in the broadcast compound and
they're all you know frame sick but they
don't care time of day but when we're
measuring the position of you know
sailboats or things it's easiest to just
use GPS time because it's cheaply
available everywhere the NASCAR NASCAR
was introduced in 2001 this is the it's
been used in every NASCAR race
this was the first generation of the
enquirer sensor we're now on the third
generation that's a ring laser gyro it
had an art TK GPS that had you know 2
centimeter measurement accuracy you can
see the cooling duct the NASCAR was a
challenge because there's an overhanging
metal fence and you can only see half
the sky from a race car and some of
these small tracks you do a lap of the
track once a minute so you can't see
anyone satellite for more than a minute
so you're constantly changing satellites
plus there's overpasses where you're
losing everything so we had to cheat and
some of the ways we cheated where we
would digitize the ribbon of track in
three space so we knew to only consider
ambiguous solutions that were on that
ribbon of track and then we also used of
course the inertial navigation system so
we could dead reckon so to speak through
gaps and not have to go through the
whole recall a shin and rejection of
ambiguous solutions phase and it was it
really astonished the GPS community when
we got GPS to work at an art TK
precision of two centimeters in a
situation where you had race cars going
200 miles an hour and they could only
see half the sky and they could never
see any satellite for longer than about
45 seconds so it really was a surprising
success in that case yes um we weren't
using sudo lights we were of course to
do rtk you need to do reference phase
measurements to the satellites and we
had our own reference station at the
racetrack and of course we do that in
the America's Cup as well the principal
objective of the system was that center
field at centre video which is to allow
the commentators to talk about who's who
and to allow the commentators to talk
about a race and it's sometimes tricky
to do so when the leaders in the race or
in the middle of the pack because
they've lapped everybody and they're all
in the back stretch and even though the
cars are all different colors they all
look grey when
they're in the back stretch and so this
allowed the commentators to tell the
story of a race in a much clearer way
than they ever could before but then
once we had that data the data got used
for you know lower and upper third
graphics and the TV and then I got used
for mobile apps and for people to keep
track of the race you know on the
internet and from their phones and so
forth so it turned out to be a very
successful system and has started to be
used in timing and scoring by NASCAR we
did a number of things for the Olympics
this was of course the 2002 Olympics
this was speed skating the principal
objective of the system was to measure
the skaters put lines on the ice in to
show where the skaters were relative to
the fastest skater in a previous heat
were relative to the world record or
previous gold medal pace we were asked
to do something additional which is to
put graphic images of the flags on the
ice so they could tell the nationality
of the skater we did it with a very soft
alpha so it looked as though the flags
were kind of under the ice but we knew
we were successful when we were
criticized for having tripped the
Canadian
and in fact we were similarly successful
in the America's Cup both in Plymouth
and here in San Francisco when the event
was criticized for polluting the water
with the ink so the America's Cup it's
the oldest continuously running event in
the history of sport and part of the
reason it's the oldest running event is
it's got a very very quirky structure in
that whoever wins the cup becomes the
new trustee and gets to completely make
all the decisions from that point
forward so it's sort of like if you win
the Super Bowl you get to run the NFL
and the bad news about that is that it
causes lots of controversy and delay the
good news about it is whenever the
America's Cup starts down the wrong path
at some point it gets reinvented and I
think that's why the America's Cup will
never end is that we'll just constantly
get reinvented because you get an
entirely new management group every time
somebody wins the darn thing but it
makes the business of the America's Cup
very very difficult because the
America's Cup can't make long-term
commitments to sponsors or to
broadcasters or two venues because you
can't commit yourself beyond the next
cup because you don't know whether you
will have won it or not this is an
excerpt from the cup watch for the
graphics on the water which is the stuff
that I'm going to be talking about
ok
more to talk about
that was unbelievable
winner of the Long Beach
the entire sailing world holds its
breath from the start of the 34
can it get
whoa
the post Allman cars we like to use the
postponement are we next to guy back and
regroup we feel left
salamat
thank you
the Kiwis now just blew it away from the
America's Cup
it's not over so all right
imagine these guys lost from here what
an upset that would be our then it'd be
one hell of a story that'll be one hell
of a combat that's my motivation
that comeback is complete
you
whoa enter
d
so the the TV was good but obviously we
benefited enormously from having a great
story the fact that the Kiwis got you
know drawl the way to game point and
then oracle came all the way back it was
just one of the best stories in all of
sport so it made it easier to do a great
job of the TV having a story like that
so these are the things that we did here
you can see a number of the important
elements you can see the hundred meter
lines the trails behind the boats the
ley lines which of these gold lines
which are the points at which a boat can
tack and get all the way to the mark
without tacking again or jibe with it
and get to the mark without diving again
you can see the gates those yellow
circles they're not acting in this case
their circle no they're not circles
because those are mark boats but what
those are those are the zones around the
marks so those are the three boat
lengths owns that are three boat lengths
from the edge of the mark so we use
those to not only indicate where the
marks are for the viewer but those are
the points at which the rules change for
the sailors that's the point where
different rules come into place for who
gets the right to go around the mark on
the inside this is a World Series event
in Venice I think here you can see the
hundred meter lines the trails behind
the boats the the mark zones as well and
then you can see the boundaries those
white boundaries along the edge and
those boundaries were sort of artificial
limits you get a penalty if you touch
one of those boundaries this is some
excerpts showing the live line stuff the
stuff that my group did
so this is a match racing start you can
see the entry lines change color at the
instant though you know one minute two
minutes before the start
the starting line will change color at
the instant of the start there you can
see the ley lines and the hundred-meter
lines and the trails behind the boats
the hundred meter lines ended up being
enormously important I think because of
the analogy to football so sports fans
could just look at that and even though
the boats are all going in different
directions they could tell who's ahead
and who's behind because of the analogy
to a football field it was something
that was far more important than we had
by when we put that in as a graphic
element but as soon as we saw it
everybody just said that's something
that we got to use a lot of that's I
have to go back and look to see whether
it might have been a compression
artifacts just been a mistake they're
all of this video is coming by RF from
the helicopter so that it's not so from
time to time there'd be a furnell
cancellation or something and we'd get a
drop out here you'll see the start
change color
nothing like the letter R p.m. i'll talk
a little bit more about penalties but
they ended up using our data for
electronic umpiring so this is how
sailing used to look on TV just a bunch
of boats on a blue background and then
if you fade in the live line effects
suddenly it's easy to say it's easy to
tell who's ahead because of the analogy
to a football field and then if you fade
out the live line effects again you can
see just how difficult it is for the
commentators to tell a story to that
plus there's the problem that the boats
are going in different directions and so
to a new fan they ask the question well
if it's a race why are they going in
different directions but just like a
football field people understand that
you don't always run straight down the
field sometimes you go laterally
sometimes even go backwards but you can
still tell who's ahead by seeing who's
furthest down the field so that analogy
to a football field just turned out to
be enormously useful now before the
start in a match race you can't cross
the starting line before the clock gets
to zero but there's no bonus on being
crossing the starting line quick shortly
after time equals zero the bonus is
crossing the starting line before the
other guy so the whole tactic of a match
race is to mess with the other boat put
him in a tough spot and then start
before him and if you both start 30
seconds late it doesn't matter as long
as you start before him so there's this
major dance that takes place before the
start and it's very difficult for the
commentators to explain without these
kind of graphics
the entry is kind of like boxing you
have to start from your corner at a
certain time and then then it's all on
you know the battle and then you have to
cross the starting line you know when
the after the clock gets to zero but all
of the but having this kind of tool to
where people can see where the starting
line is see where the entry sides are
and see the trails of the boats it's
very helpful that for the commentators
to describe the tactics of the race of
the start going all the way back to the
stuff that we originally proposed a
David Hill you can put stuff into the
real world that isn't really there this
is a relatively tasteful example of the
America's Cup logo there's some very
commercial crass examples and there was
one practical joke that never actually
made it to air but we thought it would
have been good this is this is how you
tell when an engineering group is
finally getting caught up as you start
to see stuff like this and the preview
monitor in the production room and now
you'll see a submarine coming up out of
the water this is the gear that we had
on the boats the battery Pelican case
had a bad at kilowatt hour of power this
is the brain box these were all
hand-built by my group it has the rtk
GPS the inertial navigation system so it
is able to measure the position of the
boats and marks and motorboats 22
centimeters than the orientation to a
tenth of a degree and heading pitch and
roll it also looks after all of the
communications that you know for the
camera control the umpire in control all
of that the seguin use the cell phone
network the interesting question the
question was did we use the cell network
for data and the answer is never in
professional sports do you ever rely on
the cell phone network because the first
thing that happens when fans show up is
that whatever Wi-Fi networks exist in
whatever cell phone network exists
becomes very flaky and so you don't even
use it to call one another
you have to have you know licensed
spectrum with handheld radios and so
forth so now the answer is that you
could use it in principle for an event
that nobody showed up but that would be
up the yeah and the cell phone network
in general doesn't cover the water very
well because there's very few people out
there you know a few fishermen and the
phone companies are smart they don't
waste resources in areas where there's
hardly ever people but in the same
things true you know even in stadiums
the cell companies try very hard to
provide coverage but it's difficult and
you will all experience that when you're
at you know a ballpark or something the
there ended up with six Pelican cases on
the America's Cup boats you had to
battery Pelley's one brain box pelle
then there was two video processing
Pelley's and one audio processing pelle
this is a sort of a diagram of the
masthead of the top of the wing of the
boat this is the power amplifier and the
antenna for the TV backhaul from the
boat that was capable of transmitting on
214 megahertz wide microwave channels
I'm simultaneously and we could put 27
megabit per second HD feeds into each
channel so we could bring up to 4 HD
channels off of a single boat at the
same time we had a total of fourteen
channels that we could use and those 14
channels had to be allocated between
three helicopters the to chase boats all
of the race boats and so we were
constantly telling different boats to
move to different channels and turning
the power turning the transmitters off
and on in order to use those 14 channels
as effectively as we could that was a
one-way transmission from the helicopter
chase boats sail boats to the shore it
was see OFDM so there was quite a bit of
forward error correction but there was
no acknowledgement no retrial was just a
one-time using the modulation that of
course is common in Britain for
terrestrial transmission or common in
Europe for terrestrial transmission then
this is the two
wait'll imagery Network our to wait till
amatory network was full off
acknowledgement retry you know IP we use
that to control the cameras so we could
control the pan tilt zoom focus of six
of the seven cameras on each of the
America's Cup boats we used it to
control the umpiring system so we could
turn the penalty and protest lights off
and on we used it to send the reference
phase measurements of the GPS system to
the boats so that the boats could do the
rtk calculations on board the boats and
of course we used it to get the position
of the boats as well as the orientation
you know back to shore that Network ran
at a very steady rate of about 400
kilobits per second we used ubiquity
radios that were modified to run outside
the Wi-Fi band we use the ubiquity
airmax protocol which is a tdma protocol
so it's time slotted so it very
efficiently handled the fact that we had
a very very steady data rate and then we
we used a sort of an stb see a
space-time block coding approach so that
we had multiple antennas at different
heights that are accessed at points on
shore so that when one of the antenna
has had a frenetic cancellation problem
the other one was almost guaranteed to
not have that same null and we pick the
antenna heights very carefully so that
the fernell cancellation wouldn't hit
both antennas at the same time the we
also didn't use we used a modulation
that didn't have any amplitude
modulation in it because the fidelis
owns you come and go very quickly so we
just used phase modulation i think it
was mcs to the helicopters this is what
made the America's Cup so much harder
than any of the other systems we did all
the other systems that we have mentioned
baseball football hockey NASCAR they all
use cameras that are mounted on tripods
so it's relatively easy to measure the
pan and tilt relative to the tripod with
optical encoders you can survey the
location of the tripod you can run wires
to it
it's very straightforward in this case
the America's Cup all of the video that
you do live line in is taken from
helicopters and the helicopters are
remarkably far away from the race you
know over a thousand feet away so the
orientation of the camera is really
really critical so we needed to measure
the position of the helicopter to a few
centimeters but we needed to measure its
orientation in space to a hundredth of a
degree and then we needed to measure the
orientation of the camera relative to
the helicopter to a hundredth of a
degree it turned out the helicopters
weren't stiff enough so we had to put
the navigation system on the same
mounting plate as the camera because the
helicopter itself you know would bend
more than a hundredth of a degree we
ended up instrumenting two of the
helicopters for the final America's Cup
you know two of the three and hear the
helicopters they love sort of flying in
formation and they'd be whistling the
mash theme song as they flew under the
race course yeah this is a we had seven
HD cameras on every America's Cup boat
six of them were remotely controlled so
that there was a cameraman back on the
compound sitting in a steel box with the
joystick who could pan tilt zoom focus
the cameras and control the wiper the
race encoded in Riveter this imagery was
we had a public server that was
disclosed to the public and all of the
live data from the entire system was
made available to the public and that is
that is literally everything the
position of the boats 22 centimeters
their orientation to a tenth of a degree
and it's all still posted in log files
nervous costs were I cry much kaori the
different nations very very secretive
about their simulations their data yes
it's a really good question and there's
two approaches to handling those sort of
concerns
one approach is you keep the data all
super secret and you encrypt it and then
you try to convince everybody that
you're trustworthy and you're not
sneaking data to the defender and
everybody worries about the defender
gaining an advantage because the
defender is after all paying us all so
we took the opposite approach which is
we made all of the data public wide open
and then all of the teams would look at
the data and they couldn't imagine any
data that we had that wasn't disclosed
to everybody and so the fact that all of
the data was public wide open gave all
of the teams the comfort that they were
all being evenly handled and it was a it
was an interesting approach it worked
very well that the wealthy teams thought
it was great because they had more
analysts and they could get more out of
the data and the poor teams thought it
was great because they could learn
quickly from the wealthy teams by
looking at the data so everybody liked
the approach and then it was nice for my
group because we didn't have to have
people worrying about you know our
trustworthiness yes they were happy
tweet there's loes was all yesterday huh
that just means you're publishing data
well that each of the teams could check
the data relative to their own
measurements so they could make sure but
no we didn't monk I think you did it's a
trust issue second question is these
boats are very tuned does anybody really
object to where you wanted to put your
cases or did you give them freedom to
where the put the cases you put it over
your 40 pounds I guess oh yeah this way
there it was weight but it was in the
class rule and then the we even provided
dummy waits for the teams so that if the
teams were out tuning or measuring their
boats without the electronics just like
in NASCAR we would give them dummy
packages that they could bolt in the
dummy packages you know had rocks and
concrete and steel plates in them but
they were exactly the same way so the
boat would have all the same moments of
inertia but the boat wouldn't measure
without the gear on it because it was
part of the class rule and the same
thing is true of race cars
that a race car won't NASCAR race car
won't pass tech inspection without
either a dummy package in it or the real
electronics in it so there was seven
camera seven HD cameras of which we
could bring four back at once six of
them were remotely controlled pencilled
zoom focus the remotely controlled
cameras are these black spheres so
there's three in the back one on
centerline one on each side this is the
umpiring light where you can see the
protest and penalty and zone entry
symbols and this is the navigation
antenna that's a GPS received dish here
you can see two of the cameras in the
front this one is on the aft beam but
those are that that one is on the front
beam and that one there is on the prod
there's also one down here that's facing
aft that one can't be Penn tilted and
zoomed then here you can see the front
cameras there's a camera on the tip of
the prod and then there's the two
cameras on the side this is one of the
marks of the America's Cup and you can
see it's got a wind sensor at the top we
also measure the marks 22 centimeters
and that's the telemetry radio that's
the umpiring lights there's three lights
these are very bright LED strobe lights
much like you'd find in a cop car
there's a green one that goes off when
the boats within three boat lengths of
either the boundary or a mark there's a
red one that goes off when the boat
files or protest and there's a blue one
that goes off when that boat receives a
penalty just like the blue light you see
in your rear-view mirror when you
receive a Bentley this is the symbol
this is the display that we provided for
the boats that the boats could use to to
file a protest by pushing a white flag
protest we can see the start time the
number of penalties the number of meters
to the limit this is sort of a chatter
text where they could see what's going
on who else has gotten penalties who
else has filed protests we also provided
all of this data to the general public
but we provided this data on the IP
network on the boat
so the teams could use their own user
interfaces if they wanted but this was
the backup UI that we provided for them
that they could use that we put on the
boat and it was our responsibility to
make sure this one worked I think many
of the teams actually used this one we
had telemetry access points I think
about six of them scattered around the
bay the wii Haywired stabilized dish
that's intended to be used on yachts to
point at satellites we Haywired that to
point a dish at the helicopter so we had
a high-gain antenna pointing at the
helicopter and then the sector antennas
were used for the telemetry network to
and from all the boats and marks and
umpire boats and motorboats and you can
see we used a you know vertical spacing
of the antennas to space out the free
Nelson cancellation the US Coast Guard
was just outstanding it was just a
delight to work with actually the
federal government across the board but
the US Coast Guard the National Park
Service gave us a lot of grief about
trying to set up telemetry on Alcatraz
but it turns out the Coast Guard owns
the lighthouse so the Coast Guard let us
put our antennas on top of the
lighthouse which is the perfect place
forum even helped us carry the gear up
there one thing that was interesting
though is they asked us to do a full off
electro magnetic susceptibility test on
the lighthouse to make sure that our you
know 2 gigahertz transmissions that you
know a tenth of a watt wouldn't
interfere with their incandescent light
bulb turns out it didn't but now the
Coast Guard was absolutely terrific to
work with this is a TV production room
at out on the end of pier 45 through the
cup turns out you can see the live line
effects on their preview monitors and
this is fairly traditional for like an
NFL a game you know a sunday night or
monday night football game you'd see a
production room that looks about that
same level of complexity this is the
live line system in operation this is
the MDS s operator this is the guy who's
looking at the
overall health of the system so he's
looking at the health of every computer
on the system the computers that are on
the race boats the marks the motor boats
making sure everything is calibrating
everything's working well watching
temperatures and battery voltages and
all of that this is the graphics
container I'm Allen Trimble who actually
was head of media technology at SGI he
was the guy who pioneered the original
virtual graphics for the America's Cup
in 92 in San Diego he i worked with 80
very closely in the original development
of the first down line and the k-zone
for ESPN 80 then had a change of career
he went back to school got his PhD in
marine biology and now teaches in
Washington State but I dragged him out
of his new career to be the operator of
the live line system because I needed
somebody who's a competitive sailor as a
Diaz who understand computer graphics
and understands TV he was the perfect
guy to run it so he actually was the
operator of the system ken mellons the
colleague of mine from SR I we worked
together for 35 years now he's his job
during the actual operation was to look
after the reregistration of the system
and kenwood served as the chief engineer
of the whole system as he did for NASCAR
I'm looking after the telemetry system
and I look after the system wind meaning
the wind direction and speed that's used
for the umpiring system and used for the
ley lines in 100 meter lines this is a
view over eighty shoulder what 80 is
doing is the live line operator is
listening on intercom to the producer
and director listening to what the story
is going to be about listening to the
commentators what they're saying
figuring out how he can help with live
line telling the helicopters where to go
telling the cameramen what to shoot and
then pulling up the graphic effects so
if he hears the producer say saying
something like well looks like so and so
is getting pretty close to the boundary
he'll get the helicopter in place get
the cameraman get it framed up put up
the boundaries and just about the time
the commentators start to talk about it
there'll be a perfect graphic
he was just outstanding at that this is
the key operator we only we try to not
draw on the boats so what we do is we
try to capture the colors that are on
the water and only key on them and this
is sort of a preview rendering where
we've turned every pixel yellow that we
would key on if there were graphics and
so if this guy is doing his job right
what you should see is a boat sailing
around on in a yellow ocean and it was
much much tougher to do to operate the
key for sailing than it is for football
because sailing the color of the water
changes based on whether it's a puff or
a lul or the angle of the Sun or the
angle of the helicopter and so it was
really difficult to do that right then
it mostly worked these are the
commentators Gary Johnson who's won the
America's Cup is tactician Kenny read
who's won just about everything else in
sailing world champion in a number of
classes he's president of north sails
they're obviously paying attention this
is todd harris who is the only
professional commentator he was having
trouble staying awake and Todd was
amazing he was so skilled and so relaxed
that he'd be texting his kids at the
same time they're on air and whenever
the broadcast would get in trouble Todd
would parachute in and get us out of
trouble well here we are in san
francisco now let's take a look at and
nail off you go but it was really
helpful to have a true professional
broadcaster involved the one that guys
that run the America's Cup figured out
that we knew where the boats were within
two centimeters and a tenth of a degree
they decided to use that for the
management of the races so this is John
Craig the principal race officer who
these strip charts show the wind
direction and speed at every mark and at
every motor boat this is the screen that
John uses to specify what the race
course is you know what marks you go
round in what order and this is the
screen that John uses where he can drag
the mark locations and drag the boundary
locations and then all of that data once
he drags it is sent out to the race
boats to the mark boats to TV and to the
internet and is instantly available to
everybody
this is the umpiring the umpires
similarly when they figured out that we
knew where the votes were within two
centimeters in the tenth of a degree
they wanted to use it for the umpiring
some umpire calls or judgment calls it
you know a judgment of whether a boat
had room an opportunity was able to
avoid a collision or keep clear other
umpiring calls that were based purely on
facts did a boat cross the starting line
too early did about touch the boundary
where two boats overlap the instant the
closest boat got to the zone surrounding
the mark those aren't based on
interpretation or judgement those are
just simply based on measurements and so
by using our data the umpires could get
rid of the mistakes that sometimes get
made in sailing events through
interpretation and different points of
view so there were some umpires in the
water like this guy in a jet ski and
those umpire boats and then some of the
umpires were in a booth and the umpires
in a booth would make all of the
decisions that were based on fact you
know was there an overlap its own entry
and the umpires on the water would make
the decisions that were based on
judgement it was interesting they tried
for a while to umpire with jet skis they
had to in order to be fast enough they
had to get 300 horsepower jets cruise
then they discovered the umpires
couldn't run the jet skis so they had to
hire Navy SEALs to teach the umpires how
to drive the jet skis in fact that's a
Navy Seal and then they discovered that
it was easier to teach the Navy SEALs
how to umpire than it was to but at the
end of the day even the Navy SEALs
couldn't keep up with the boats so this
is an offshore racing powerboat that's
capable of going 80 knots in rough seas
and this is a very maneuverable rib that
they use for the starting area and for
the vicinity of marks and so the on the
water umpires ended up in these two
boats this is what the umpires actually
see this is just a screen grab of what
they see so this is two boats
approaching the lured mark that is coots
you see the zone change color the
instant you see that spittle is not
overlapped spittle is going on
the inside even though he's not entitled
to he will get protested by Koontz and
he will win that protest these two
yellow boats are the umpire boats so the
umpires in the booth can see where their
colleagues on the water is that's a jet
ski and that's a speedboat so this is a
replay so notice when Koontz first
touches the zone the zone changes color
then you'll see at that instant there
was no overlap in fact there's not an
overlap until now now there's an overlap
so spittle is not entitled to go in
there so he's going to get a penalty so
the umpires have the ability to zoom in
zoom out go backwards and forwards in
time to find you know the exact instant
to make a call and of course they're
under a lot of time pressure to make the
call quickly and then these sort of
replays get used in the umpire review
meetings after the fact this is an event
in Venice turns out that this boundary
is actually a stone wall and this is a
mark and all of these boats are supposed
to go through here and when they laid
out the course they had no idea that
they were all going to get here at the
same time and clearly there's not enough
room for them so they're all banging
into in one another but the reason we
like to show this is that it gives you a
feeling for just how accurate the
tracking really is meaning when we claim
that it was two centimeters and a tenth
of a degree the sailors were incredulous
at the time but then when incidents like
this happened that were perfectly
rendered on the screen they came around
understanding that in fact the tracking
system worked extraordinarily well say
again these are the ac45 not larger now
and at this point the umpires are just
furious they can't believe they've been
put in a situation where there there was
an impossible situation where the boats
could never fit through there and
everybody's protesting and the whole
thing has gone to custard
this is a the data also got used by
mobile apps so we made the data publicly
available to everybody live there was a
mobile app that the America's Cup paid
for it was the official one it was done
by virtual spectator and it was a very
good one but that same data was
available to everybody else and so half
a dozen mobile apps got developed and
some of them were very good and some of
them had you know particularly
particular strengths but it was really
fun to see lots of other people start to
use that data and the teams use the data
themselves to analyze their performance
in each other's performance this is
something we never used but it was cool
so I thought I'd show it but what we did
is we took the detailed title model for
for San Francisco Bay this is a 12 hour
cycle and we rendered it with the
particle tool from Nvidia actually and
the interesting thing is even though all
sailors are used to the vector field
data you know in sort of a grib format
it gridded binary format you can sort of
get a feel for the dynamics of the
sloshing and the momentum and the eddies
by watching this and you can see things
in the data that you're almost
impossible to visualize in other ways
there's certain places in here where the
current actually never floods it's just
constantly ebbing and it turns out to be
the case but it was a very interesting
way to render the data the reason we
couldn't show it this way on TV is we
could never get a helicopter up that
high quick enough so it didn't turn out
to be practical we did show it in other
ways that were kind of less interesting
with with vector arrows control this is
a shows the bad air off of the wings you
can see the tip vortex on the top and
then you can also see the vortex at the
bottom of the wing we base the data from
some computer fluid dynamic calculations
that oracle racing gave us but all CFD
data from boats and airplanes is done in
a boat or airplane centered world
where you have a parent wind angle in
apparent wind speed and what we had to
do was to take those calculations and
move those air particles into the real
world so they would continue to go down
wind as the boat stopped or kept going
or change course and it turned out to be
extraordinarily accurate meaning
whenever a boat got into the bad air you
would see their performance dropped and
in many cases you'd see their weather
hull flop into the water as soon as they
got into the bad air so it turned out to
be a real fun part of the project but it
also turned out to be far more effective
than we we had imagined we only
introduced this towards the end of the
America's Cup now this is something that
was just fun what we did is we realized
that we had a 3d model of the world we
were tracking two helicopters as well as
everything relative in on the surface of
the planet and so what we did is just to
sort of show off we showed that we could
you know render things much like the air
particles in that previous video but we
could sort of show off the fact that we
really are doing everything in three
space so here we have one helicopter
that's viewing this it's camera is
panning tilting and zooming and then
we're looking at another helicopter and
then in the background you see stuff
well you don't see it now but you will
see stuff that's actually on the surface
of the world here you can see the shadow
of the fake particles and then you can
also see stuff in the real world and we
actually did this to try to show the red
bull air races that this would be a
great way for them to ask us to do
augmented reality for the Red Bull Air
racing which they didn't do but it was a
fun it was a fun project and the
interesting thing about this was it only
took us about two hours to pull this
together once we thought it would be a
fun thing to try and then the other
thing you notice of course is if you ask
a helicopter pilot to go blast around
that's a cakewalk they love doing that
this is another thing where the Coast
Guard and the federal government were
just hugely helpful to us but as any of
you who are sailors know that all
Mariners now use a system called a is
where every boat transmits its position
much like aircraft should do or
sometimes do and that's visible by all
other vessels and what we wanted to do
is we wanted to use a is to communicate
to the fleet of spectator boats where
the boundaries of the racecourse were
but there's nothing actually along those
boundaries so there's nothing where you
could put a transponder and AIS
transponder beacon so what we wanted to
do given the fact that we knew where the
boundary was is we wanted to transmit
spoof a is positions from shore so I've
because of another business I've been
active in I call the woman I work with
at the FCC closely and said well here's
what we want to do we want to take this
you know federal government a is Channel
and we want to send these spoof signals
out showing where things are that aren't
actually there and I think she fell out
of her chair she was laughing so hard
and she explained to me that you know
I'd be in jail forever if we did say
father so I asked her okay what would it
take you know for us to be get
permission to do that she said well she
looked it up and she said those
frequencies are actually controlled by
the Coast Guard so within two days I was
on the phone with Admiral Schultz at the
Coast Guard and Admiral Schultz thought
this is a great idea the Coast Guard
would love to be able to do this if a
warship comes in and they want to put a
temporary security zone around it or if
there's an oil spill and they want to
keep people out of the way so Admiral
Schultz said here's what we'll do I'll
give you the right to do it and then you
just have to show us what you did
because we'd love to be able to explore
this for the Coast Guard so he sent a
letter to the FCC and I get this call
back from the same woman at the FCC
saying how did you do that
but it worked great so we transmitted
the signals from shore and then all of
the spectator boats could see where the
boundary of the course was and if John
Craig changed it that would all change
right away and folks that even that had
an iPad could see where they were
because you can see this a is data on
various websites so it worked really
well it was one of those you know
projects that we just sort of stumbled
into on the on the end and everybody
told us we couldn't do it so we figured
what the hell we have a go so overall
this was my group I had ten guys it was
like Camelot because we'd work together
most of us through our entire career so
it was a great opportunity for me to get
the gang back together and a couple of
the guys who had to pull out of
retirement but once everybody started
joining in you had to beat everybody
else away so it was just a wonderful
group of folks and we ended up saying
yes to an awful lot of projects on the
live line project that was the original
reason that we started the group was to
do the graphics on the water the virtual
a is I just described interview radios
for the interviewing the sailors on the
boats we did the load cells for the AC
45s there was a tragedy where Bart
Simpson was killed in a when an ac72
broke up in the aftermath of that we
were asked to design and build systems
to detect missing crew members after an
accident and to locate missing crew
members which we did we did the umpiring
system that I talked about the race
management system that I talked about
and then it was a lot of it was based on
the data network and the data network
was both telemetry out under the race
course we made all that data available
in the compound to anybody that wanted
it for computer graphics and then of
course it was all available on the
public Internet we had a slave server
and the that data network was used to
control the pan tilt zoom focus of the
cameras on the boats the virtual
graphics that were used on air the
mobile apps went to open source data the
teams used it to analyze performance we
did the official results on the database
and then the data major changes like
lead changes
and penalties and protests we even had a
twitter feed hooked to our database
system so that it would automatically
tweet the data so it ended up being you
know a huge huge project and and lots of
fun we ended up being on budget and on
schedule and we did everything we said
we were going to do and more so it was a
it was a really fun project this was the
team of guys you can notice that the old
guys who have knees that hurt are all
standing up in the back and the young
guys have been kneel in the front but it
was a it was a great group so that
concludes my formal comments but I
delighted to take any questions in the
yes hydrofoils played a major role and
I'm trace whether the control data
associated with the hydrofoils somehow
got streamed or is now in a place where
people can analyze this know that any
all that foil data we didn't have any
sensors on it we did have sensors on the
rudder but just the just the steering
affects the rudder there wasn't in this
particular event they weren't allowed to
change the pitch of the rudder anyway
but no the the data about the
orientation in the shape of the wing and
the foils was not part of the public
data configuration because sometimes
boats lose hold of the water and some of
the most spectacular events could be
foreshadowed through the dynamic control
systems of the hydrofoils and there
wasn't a didn't actually have dynamic
control system whether what it was all
manual control a lot of controversy
because the key we thought the Americans
did but there's no evidence that they
actually did but all of the dynamic data
for the parts themselves meaning five
Hertz position heading pitch and roll
and heave you know hike yeah it's all in
the data Oh so there's a lot to be
learned from how those systems work just
by looking at the orientation and
location of the platform yes
if magician we're going to take a coin
and flip it eight times and they're all
heads and they gave it to me a knife up
to date times it wasn't even matched and
then he put the date times and they're
all tails I would conclude there were
three different coins you know you
somehow early on the American boat
didn't do real well then there was a
period of fluctuations and then it just
wiped everything else now what changed
in that middle there that those couldn't
have been the same another thing boat
literally but there had to have been
some changes in strategy or changes in
yeah I remember always building the
oracle team i think had enormous
potential but they were quite arrogant
and they weren't paying attention to the
data and they didn't know that they were
slow and it was evident to us that they
were slow because we of course were
paying attention and looking at the data
and it was evidenced to some others that
they were slow but they didn't know and
so then what happened was as soon as
they started racing the kiwis they got
instant focus in humility and they as
they lost you know eight races and the
oracle team had fabulous equipment and
extraordinary designers and
extraordinary sailors and once they had
you know total focus they very very
quickly started to figure out what the
kiwis were doing there was so much
better and the Kiwis were tacking much
better the Kiwis were configuring their
boat much better and so then what Oracle
did with some relatively small changes
they increased the gap in their wings so
there was a larger gap between there the
main element of the wing and the flaps
they trimmed the wing differently with
more twist they raked the wing back to
load the rudders up more they started
tacking the way the Kiwis tack where you
you use the foils to hold the boat up
during the tax you don't have these
lossy skinny hulls being torqued through
the water sideways and they basically
they went to school in the Kiwis and
they just studied a lot of the Kiwis
techniques figured it out and then got
good and I think a couple of interesting
things one is no Larry should have been
furious with the oracle team
here he had given them all this time and
all this money and all this potential
and they showed up for the first race of
the america's cup so ill-prepared
they're given their potential they
should have won every race which would
have been bad for TV but they should
have won every race there was no there
was no excuse for them not having you
know swept the series the the other
thing was interesting about the Kiwis as
they made a critical mistake which is
they had the Americans in their back
foot and they were winning every race
and then there was one critical race
about halfway through the series where
unless both teams agreed that was going
to be a race on that day and the Oracle
suggested that they turned it into a ley
de and the Kiwis agreed an Oracle made
enormously effective use of that laid a
practicing and developing techniques and
had the Kiwis you know the Kiwis you
know pardon the slang expression the
Kiwis had you know their foot on
oracle's throat and they should have
just kept it there and instead what they
did is they let Oracle you know have
this day and that was the day that kind
to turn things around there's one other
thing that happened that I don't know
how widely known it is but that race
where the Kiwis almost capsized and came
flopping down when they flopped down I
think they broke the damaged one of
their appendages when that horizontal
section of the appendage hit the water
and so then from the races after that
they went to their second string
appendages so at the same time the
Oracle boat is learning how to sail and
speeding up the Kiwis were slowing down
but it was a really interesting effect
and as far as I can tell it wasn't
scripted hell I'll close with your
working relationship with Oracle and hey
during the race and they were paying for
it rivalry pretty much in the office
sounds like they were
they were misleading Kelvin as well yeah
I had to be really careful because I
started to work for the cup in as soon
as I got back from there round the world
record in mid-2010 and then for the
first year I was both running
performance for Oracle meaning doing all
their instrumentation and leading their
electronics group and I was also leading
the AC tech group and then as the cup
got closer I had to pick one job or the
other then I picked the AC tech job
because the other teams would have gone
ballistic to have me working for both
and then at that point you know our
whole group had to be super careful to
deal with Oracle and an absolutely arm's
length basis and so when we noticed that
Oracle had a problem in their
performance you know leading up to the
cup because we're watching them and
we're watching the Kiwis we had to be
very careful not know well yeah there
was a few scenes in the bar word you
know fresh is saying that they're in
good shape and they're fast and I'm kind
of going oh god but now we were all we
were all very very careful yes is the
system the IP for all of this now I was
interesting so that basically the
augmented reality stuff was all
developed by sport vision which is the
company I've co-founded 98 I left sport
vision to sail full-time in 2004 and
then when this opportunity came along to
do this for the cup I didn't want to
have to recreate everything so what we
did is we did a deal with sport vision
where we built this system on top of the
base technology that support vision had
and so we extended sport visions
technology with the ability to operate
from a moving camera and a helicopter
and to do the sailing stuff and then
sport vision has the right to use that
for all other sports but the America's
Cup has the exclusive right to use it
for any water sport so it ended up being
a very positive arrangement and then for
a lot of the TV operators we hired sport
vision guys to be the operator so we
ended up with a very friendly
relationship with sport vision and it
worked well because we were able to
extend their system
and of course we knew it because we
built it so so a lot of these guys that
were in the AC tech group were the
original founding engineering group from
sport vision and we discovered that
nobody had really been in our code since
we left for the next America's Cup
nobody else yes variations to 20 system
like that and normally you wouldn't
normally these kinds of systems are only
used by really financially successful
sports like baseball football NASCAR and
in through the years you know I think
I've probably written 25 proposals to
sports like you know volleyball
badminton lacrosse and it never works
out you know they look at what these
things cost and they say this is crazy
it's just nuts and so when they asked us
to do it for sailing in the first place
yeah that's basically what I said which
is hey we can do it but you can't afford
it and then they said well you don't
understand Larry is trying to turn this
into a major sport and and so we did do
it the first year but I don't know
whether it'll be affordable top rate for
future comes
you